I just told Jonathan this story the
other day and it's a lesson to all of us
and me and you and anyone my mother
tells this story because she was at a
football game at Rice stadium in Houston
uh one Sunday she saw Joe DiMaggio and
she went over to him and she said oh my
God Mr DiMaggio it's so could I have
your autograph and he said well yeah all
right and she said oh I don't have a
pencil and he went well get a pencil and
she said okay she ran off to get a
pencil and she came back and he was gone
and to this day if you see well all
through my youth whenever the Mr Coffee
commercials would come on my mother
would say oh he's a terrible man
terrible man